[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
following the discovery of a warrant
from 70 years ago a grand jury declines
to indict carolyn bryant donham the
woman whose accusations led to the
lynching of emmett till and the death of
nba great kobe bryant making headlines
once again as the lawsuit his wife filed
against los angeles county heads to
trial plus this case is not resolved
until we have a successful prosecution
and people are held accountable an
arrest is made after four muslim men
were murdered over the last nine months
in new mexico but first kylie we love
you and if you see this please just
please just come home
the search intensifies for missing
california teenager kylie rodney law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm your host mike saks family and
friends of a missing california teenager
are pleading for her safe return kylie
rodney hasn't been seen by her family or
friends since last weekend law and
crime's angenet levy is here with more
on the case and the search for the
missing teen internet
well my kylie rodney was last seen over
the weekend it was actually early
saturday morning at a campground in
northern california a spokesperson for
the placer county sheriff's office tells
me that marine units are searching a
body of water nearby and there are
divers on standby it's not clear whether
they've entered the water just yet now
we want to show you a photo of kylie
rodney sheriff's officials say she and
her silver honda crv have been missing
since last weekend and there's been no
activity on her cell phone kylie is only
16 and had attended a party at the
campground with 100 people before she
went missing before that a surveillance
camera captured video of her at a truck
stop her mother has begged for anyone to
come forward with information about
kylie's whereabouts
we just want her home we're so scared
and we miss her so much and we love her
so much and kylie we love you and if you
see this please just please just come
home
i want nothing more than to hug you
and if
is anybody else out there if you know
where she is do you know anything about
where she might be
if you have any ideas or
or thoughts please um
please come forward and share them and
and we're not looking to like
bust anybody else or get anybody in
trouble we just want to see our daughter
home
now anyone with information about
kylie's disappearance is asked to call
the placer county sheriff's office that
number is on your screen it's area code
530-886-5375 and there's actually a
fifty thousand dollar reward being made
available to anyone who has information
that leads to kylie's recovery
mike thanks internet now joining me
today are long-time analyst julie
rendellman former swat member lisa
lockwood and law and crime's angina levy
now first off julie a spokesperson with
the sheriff's office told a group of
teens who attended the party quote we're
not investigating you we're partnering
with you to obtain any information
regarding kiley now does that mean that
they don't have to lawyer up or aren't
facing any criminal liability break that
down for us please
so unfortunately it doesn't and you know
it's very hard i'm a criminal defense
attorney so naturally my inclination is
to tell every single kid that was there
to have a lawyer because they may say
something innocuous and that could be
taken in a way to indicate that
something happened that didn't um the
problem is it's imperative for these
kids
to provide information if they have
information and so it's really difficult
to balance especially if you're one of
the parents of one of these kids that
may have information so a lot of times
they may hire an attorney and perhaps
that attorney can provide some
information and and
in certain ways be a shield between the
individuals and law enforcement to to
give them the information they need but
to protect the children uh that may have
seen or know something hey julian this
is certainly still a developing story
with information still coming in and
jeanette is there any information about
kylie that could help people locate her
well mike she is five feet seven inches
tall she weighs 118 pounds and we want
to tell you that she has blonde hair and
hazel eyes just in case you weren't able
to tell her eye color by looking at the
photos she also has a tattoo of the
number 17
on her ribs and she has a nose ring and
several other piercings so these are
things that people could be looking out
for particularly if you saw her at a
campground or something maybe in a
swimsuit you just never know with that
tattoo on her ribs that has the number
17. so
obviously her family is distraught and
looking to find her hopefully we all
hope alive
and janet thank you very much for that
um i'm still curious about what's
happening here
in placer county
is there any question of foul play is
there any information we're getting that
could lead to knowing where she might be
i mean we've already detailed all the
things that might be available but what
do we expect to come out in the coming
days i mean have you heard anything more
about this internet
yeah not really mike i mean they're
they're looking they're searching that
body of water right now by the
campground and so they're probably just
trying to rule that out or possibly
searching to see if her vehicle might be
in there keep in mind as we told you her
vehicle is missing so that is a key
piece if they find kylie hopefully they
find her vehicle so they're probably
just trying to rule this out we'll just
have to wait and see what comes of the
investigation
as it moves forward you've got to think
they are pinging her cell phone to
determine just exactly where she was
when that phone signal went off on
saturday yeah well thank you for that
and let's move on to our another story
here attorneys for a former south
carolina attorney and accused killer
alec murdoch are asking the judge to
delay a lawsuit until after he stands
trial for the murders of his wife and
son now murdoch was charged in the 2021
shooting of the of his wife and the
death of his wife maggie and son paul
last month and that was a year after
their deaths now this is just the latest
charge in a string of alleged crimes the
former low country attorney is charged
with murdoch faces dozens of charges
relating to alleged financial crimes
accused of swindling millions of dollars
from former clients and being part of an
alleged insurance fraud scheme in which
police say he hired someone to kill him
to get a life insurance payout for his
surviving son buster after the deaths of
maggie and paul now he's also charged
with stealing millions from a settlement
intended for the children of his former
housekeeper who died at the family's
home four years ago investigators also
say murdoch and his alleged drug dealer
conspired to buy and sell oxycodone for
almost a decade the lawsuit murdoch is
now seeking to delay stems from a 2019
boating accident in which his son's
friend mallory beach died while paul was
underage and drinking alcohol and
driving a boat owned by murdoch now the
beach family alleges murdoch is liable
for her death murdoch's attorneys want
to judge to continue the case and
temporarily block discovery of evidence
until after he stands trial for murder
his murder trial is set to be held in
january
and in california law and crime we will
be live inside the courtroom for the
final hearing for scott peterson before
a judge determines if the convicted
killer should get a new trial news of
peterson's arrest in the 2002 killing of
his wife lacey and their unborn son
connor swept the nation after their
bodies were found in the san francisco
bay months after going missing now he
was convicted and initially sentenced to
death then two years ago the california
supreme court overturned the death
sentence peterson's attorneys are
demanding a new trial alleging a juror
lied to get on to the jury in 2004.
peterson scheduled back in court
thursday ahead of the judge's decision
of whether he will be retried tune into
law and crime network for the live
coverage now still ahead online crime
daily the death of nba great kobe bryant
back in the spotlight as his wife takes
her lawsuit against los angeles county
to court but first with the help of the
community tips new mexico police take
make an arrest in the murders of four
men killed over the last nine months
[Music]
welcome back police are searching for a
motive after a man allegedly murdered
several muslim men in new mexico tips
from the community helped officials
bring in muhammad saeed in connection to
the deaths of four muslim men in
albuquerque investigators were able to
track down the volkswagen sedan
allegedly driven by the suspect in the
most recent murder that of naeem hussein
a 25 year old who was shot found shot to
death on friday muhammad afzal o hussein
was found fatally shot august 1st and
off top hussein was killed days earlier
on july 26th the first murder happened
back in november last year when police
say muhammad ahmadi was killed outside a
business he ran with his brother saeed
has been charged with murder in the
deaths of two of the men and police say
they're working on potential charges for
the murders of the other two
officials held a press conference
announcing the arrest and reassuring the
muslim community they will be washed
over closely to make sure everyone feels
safe
to the muslim community a big thank you
you put faith in us you trusted us you
passed information on to us that was
crucial and that led for us to be able
to make
an arrest in this case there is still a
lot of work that needs to be done
there's still a lot of evidence that
needs to be verified and i think that
it's important that we continue to move
in that direction so that we could build
a solid case for our district attorney's
office and the u.s attorney's office to
continue to move this case forward so
that we have successful prosecution
the albuquerque police department will
continue to be visible in the muslim
community in the days to come and
throughout the weeks to ensure that they
feel safe and that they have time to
come
back to a normal life and ensure that
they feel safety so our officers from
the albuquerque police department new
mexico state police will continue to be
visible within the community uh and to
make sure that everybody feels safe
now julie will this stay a state and
local case or may there be federal
charges here could there be federal hate
crime charges in science future
so it's a bit too early to tell we know
um at least we've heard that it sounds
like he knew at least two of the victims
it's possible he knew all four and the
question really when it comes to whether
it could be a federal hate crime is can
you prove that the motive was based on
hate based on some ethnicity he didn't
like or something like that and so i
think it's a little too early to tell i
think there's a whole lot of
investigation that still has to go into
and keep in mind they're still working
on the other two cases because they have
not been able to at least we don't know
but so far we haven't heard anything
about him being linked to the other two
murders of these two other uh men uh so
i think time will tell and lisa lockwood
thanks for joining do you think at this
point law enforcement's trying to obtain
some confession from the suspect and
what else is happening perhaps behind
the scenes
yeah right initially if he had not
lawyered up before the police had taken
him into custody when they found him in
his vehicle
yes that would be the goal of this but
the other evidence that's going to be
important is tying him to the other
murders that happened in in november and
then soon after that and what do they do
they start looking at forensic data they
look for his cell phone they do tracers
to find out if it was hitting off cell
towers they're going to look at the gun
that was used they seized his guns from
his vehicle and his home during the
search warrant and looking at shell
casings so it's a matter of going
through all of that evidence to link
them the fact that they've got him
linked to these two cases right now is
incredible he's in custody he's off the
street and now police need to continue
with their work to link him to the other
two murders and they sure will now
coming up on law and crime daily the
civil lawsuit brought about by kobe
bryant's wife vanessa begins jury
selection in los angeles plus a
mississippi grand jury makes a decision
whether to charge a woman in the nearly
70 year old case of emmett till's murder
[Music]
welcome back jury selection began
wednesday in downtown los angeles in the
trial of vanessa bryant's lawsuit
against the county following the death
of her husband nba star kobe bryant
bryant followed the lawsuit over graphic
photos taken by first responders at the
scene of the january 2020 helicopter
crash which killed the basketball star
their 13 year old daughter gianna and
seven others at least eight l.a county
deputies were accused of taking or
sharing graphic photos after the
helicopter plunged into a hillside
bryant is suing for invasion of privacy
arguing their family suffered emotional
distress after the photos were allegedly
passed around brian's attorneys say
photos of gianna and kobe's remains were
shared on at least 28 devices and by at
least a dozen firefighters the trial of
brian's lawsuit and that of orange
county financial advisor chris chester
were consolidated by a judge because he
was making many of the same allegations
machester's wife and daughter were also
killed in the crash ultimately six
jurors will decide both cases now lisa
no doubt sharing photos of a crime scene
is in poor taste now can any of these
first responders face criminal charges
or is this lawsuit as far as it can go
legally in the civil realm
well we're in the civil court because it
cannot be
filed criminally because it has to meet
a parameter
with police and emergency emergency
personnel there is something called
misconduct and does it breach the trust
in their misconduct anything that a lay
person can be charged with a police
officer and firefighter can be charged
with and a lot of things that fall under
police
misconduct are things like um
fraud or torturing a prisoner or a
sexual assault of somebody else the fact
that they did not share this publicly in
a forum where it can be seen and
preserved into perpetuity
helps these these officers who made a
terrible terrible error in their uh
judgment now julie several other
families in this case settled with the
county vanessa bryant did not and people
have called this lawsuit a money grab
now why did she take this to trial
instead of settling outside of court
so mike i hate hearing uh
the word money grab vanessa bryant does
not need anyone's money um this is about
the fact that um you know her family had
some right to privacy um and i think you
know there have been allegations prior
to this about the sharing of photos of
other individuals and so i think she's
out there making a statement and that
statement is that this is not acceptable
um and that this shouldn't be tolerated
um and you know i think there's no
question that anyone who looks at that
if it's true would recognize that you
cannot share photos
of a deceased individual at a bar or
with friends that is not the way it
works and so i think she's making a
statement to for anyone to make sure
that this does not happen again and
she's the perfect spokesperson for it
and often celebrities are at the
forefront of the right to privacy issues
and cases that go through our courts and
end up in law school casebooks now one
thing that she also might keep in mind
and she might be trying to prove is that
these these photos shock the conscience
and cause intense emotional distress and
of course it'll be up for a jury to
decide now also in celebrity news new
mexico's environment department files a
complaint for alleged safety violations
following the fatal shooting on the set
of alec baldwin's movie rust now the
department investigated the october
shooting in which alec baldwin was
shooting a prop gun during a rehearsal
the gun had live ammunition that killed
cinematographer helena hutchins and
wounded the film's director joel souza
the environment department concluded
rust movie productions llc was not
following national gun safety standards
on set and the company was issued a
citation including a more than 136
thousand dollar fine now since the state
could not settle with a production
company a complaint was filed against
them through the occupational health and
safety review commission to hold rust
movie productions accountable for the
workplace fatality the company now has
two weeks to respond then a hearing will
be scheduled no charges have been filed
in the fatal shooting now when we come
back the historic 70-year-old case of
emmett till making headlines once again
after a woman whose accusations led to
his lynching will not be charged
welcome back to law and prime daily now
a jury has been selected and opening
statements are presented in the
resentencing trial of jason wheeler a
florida man convicted more than a decade
ago in the shooting death of a lake
county deputy wheeler was convicted in
2006 of first degree murder of a law
enforcement officer using a firearm two
counts of attempted murder and two
counts of aggravated battery a year
after he shot and killed wayne coaster
and injured two other deputies during an
apparent ambush deputies coaster bill
crotty and thomas mccain the second
responded to a neighborhood call after a
domestic violence complaint from
wheeler's then girlfriend when deputies
arrived they were ambushed coaster was
shot in the head at close range and the
two other deputies were also shot after
a massive handman hunt wheeler was
involved in a second shootout with law
enforcement in which wheeler himself was
paralyzed he was ultimately sentenced to
death now years later courts determined
non-unanimous jury recommendations for
the death penalty violate florida's
state constitution the florida supreme
court has since reversed that ruling but
wheeler still must be re-sentenced
either receiving the death penalty or
life in prison and switching now to a
case from nearly 70 years ago that of
emmett till a mississippi grand jury
declines to indict the woman whose
accusations led to his murder
fourteen-year-old till was abducted and
tortured and lynched back in 1955 after
being accused of flirting with carolyn
bryant a white woman at her family's
grocery store two men brian's husband
and his brother abducted till beat him
and shot him in the head before dumping
his body in the tallahatchie river three
days later his body was found the two
men were arrested but were ultimately
acquitted by an all-white jury later
they admitted publicly to his killing
but were protected by double jeopardy
after hearing seven hours of testimony a
grand jury determined there was
insufficient evidence to invite bryant
on charges of kidnapping and
manslaughter now this comes after family
members of till unearthed an unserved
arrest warrant for bryant her late
husband and his brother which is dated
august 29 1955 a day after till was
brutally murdered now lisa are there any
further investigative steps to take at
this point or is this now a closed case
yeah
i i i don't know i don't have the answer
to that whether or not they can move
forward with anything else because of
double jeopardy in that particular case
but the accuser that's where the issue
came they brought
evidence and didn't have enough evidence
to prove that she was assaulted in any
way you have
information that he was he whistled at
her and then other information saying
that he actually groped her
we don't know it's so many years we've
got seven decades behind us and with
these um
people who admitted to the killing later
who
were charged and let go and found out
guilty by an all-white jury i mean we
weren't getting the justice that we're
we're seeing today so it's all very very
unfortunate yeah this is a pure southern
lynching that we saw then in 1955 in
which justice has been attempted to be
gained ever since for emmett hill now
julie why did the grand jury not come
back with an indictment here saying
there was insufficient evidence
so obviously we never know exactly what
they were thinking it's a secret
proceeding we know this is the second
time they've attempted to go into the
grand jury and they haven't been
successful
and and look the main thing is what lisa
talks about it's decades upon decades
and so
memories fade um you know over time we
know that in many of the cases we're
looking at today and so it's hard enough
if a case happened yesterday let alone
dealing with the case from so many years
ago and keep in mind also there was
limited evidence in regards to her
actual involvement in the murder we knew
she was related somehow we just didn't
know exactly how and so that's another
problem there's no witnesses that
actually establish she participated in
regards to that and so i think they did
an incredible job of the prosecutors in
trying to bring this case and bring some
justice to the family but unfortunately
they were unsuccessful yeah in this case
was unearthed i think by pretty good
journalism someone finding the uh the
old indictments and then also digging up
this notion that perhaps and what was
accused never happened which was largely
suspected anyway given the circumstances
socially and civilly at the time but
this is perhaps the end of an of a
chapter of a really dark chapter in uh
in the civil rights era anyway lisa
julie thank you very much for joining us
here and everyone watching also thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily we will see you next time as we
discuss justice in america thank you for
watching
[Music]
you